اجتماع اعاقبه ليس الاول من نوعه اذا شهدت
الاعوام الماضيه اجتماعات مماثله ابرزها
في طابا وشرم الشيخ لكن اللافته هذه المره
هو سياق الاحداث والتصعيد الاسرائيلي في
الضفه بما فيها القدس تزامنا مع الاجتماع
فقبل اربعه اسابيع من الان وتحديدا في
السادس والعشرين من يناير كانون الاول
كانون الثاني الماضي
قتل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تسعه فلسطينيين
بينهم سيده مسنه خلال اقتحام مدينه جنين
ومخيمها بالضفه الغربيه في عمليه عسكريه
هي الاكبر منذ انتفاضه الاقصى الثانيه عام
2002 خلفت دمارا كبيرا في المباني
والممتلكات
وفي ثالث عشر من فبراير الشباط الجاريه
وفي خطوه تمثل تحديا لتحذيرات امريكيه اقر
المجلس الامني الوزاري المصغر في اسرائيل
تشريع تسع بؤر استيطانيه غير قانونيه في
الضفه الغربيه وفي عمليه عسكريه دمويه
عادت قوات الاحتلال الاقتحام مدينه نابلس
في 22 من فبراير الجاري لترتكب مجزره في
المدينه بقتلها 11 فلسطينيا بينهم رجلان
مسنان وطفل واصابت بالرصاص الحي اخرين في
اليوم التالي لمجره نابلس صادقت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه على بناء سبعه الاف وحده
استيطانيه جديده في الضفه والقدس ووضعف ما
تمت المصادقه عليه خلال العام الماضي
باكمله ومقابل التوسع الاستيطاني اسرائيل
تمضي في هدم مباني الفلسطينيين في القدس
المحتله فخلال شهر الماضي هدم الاحتلال
اكثر من 30 منشاه مقدسيه
ويتهدد شبح الهدم اكثر من 22 الف منزل
خلال هذا العام الجاري